if the rumors we're hearing are true and
we are getting a Stargate movie before
we get a series what could that mean
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
if you are a regular side tracker you
will know that we do have contacts in
and around MGM who have been telling us
little bits of information about the
development of Stargate and a rumor that
we're hearing at the moment is that
we're actually might be getting a movie
before we're going to be getting a
series
now we do know that Amazon are looking
to other science fiction television
shows for inspiration when they're
developing Stargate and they're looking
at shows like Star Trek and the model
that they currently use and have used in
the past 10 years so I thought today
we'd take a look at this timeline of
Star Trek and compare that to what we
might potentially get should we be
getting a Stargate movie so just like
Stargate Star Trek was off the air for
quite a long time Star Trek the Next
Generation left our screens in 2005. now
unlike Stargate we did actually get more
Star Trek pretty soon after next
Generation that actually ended we got
the first movie from the Kelvin timeline
in 2009 you know the movie starring
Chris Pine Zachary Quinto the Calvin
timeline we then got Star Trek Into
Darkness and Star Trek Beyond and it was
a new Star Trek movie in development
right now coming out this year so we've
actually had quite a lot of Star Trek in
the form of movies but the way the Star
Trek films worked were it was an
alternate timeline which meant
everything that happened before kind of
still happened except
everything that happened in the movies
was an alternate timeline and everything
that came after the movie such as Star
Trek Discovery Star Trek the card
weren't necessarily influenced by what
had happened in the movies and this is
something that could potentially happen
with Stargate now this is something that
worries me as a fan of Stargate and a
fan of the television show but also a
fan of movies as a whole if they created
a Stargate movie and it wasn't
necessarily a continuation of what
happened in the TV series before and was
more of a continuation from the original
1994 movie it would add a degree of
separation between the movie franchise
and the television franchise and that's
not something I'm necessarily on board
with now we've spoken about hard reboots
soft reboots hybrid reboots
and continuations quite a lot on this
channel
the ideal situation for anyone who wants
Target to return is we want a
continuation something that honors what
happened in sg1 Stargate Atlantis and
Stargate Universe all of that should
have happened
and anything that comes next will honor
that and it will tie up loose ends and
it won't necessarily just recreate what
had already happened it would it would
honor the fact that those shows existed
and every event that happened in those
shows happened within the continuity of
a new series now it has spoken about
hybrid reboots and Star Trek is a really
good example of a hybrid reboot kind of
doing it in a in a roundabout way kind
of a good way where they cut they honor
things that happened in the past but
they change little bits here and there
now this happens in a lot of television
shows Doctor Who had a massive reboot in
2005 and it honored everything that came
before
there were specific storylines in nuhu
that kind of
brought into question things that had
happened in the classic series but in a
way that acknowledged that these events
happened but explain them away in I'd
like to say a clever way but sometimes
the storylines weren't weren't
sufficient but that's just a great with
Doctor Who at the moment Star Trek does
things pretty similar to that everything
that's happened in the original series
in Star Trek next Generation in Voyager
they happened in Discovery and Picard
but they changed certain things now none
of the things that they've changed are
particularly groundbreaking they don't
change the overall story but they did
change how the Klingons look and you
could argue that that is just because
technology is Advanced to a point where
we have better Prosthetics and things
just generally look better with a
certain way of doing things on camera
now if we have a different way of doing
things it will look better as a result
that is an argument to be made but what
I'm worried with with Stargate is if
they go down the movie route first and
they don't do a continuation
what is that going to look like because
I can really only see one of two
possibilities with a new movie it's
either going to be a continuation from
what happened with Stargate sg1 Stargate
Atlantis Target Universe and the
original 1994 movie or we're going to be
getting a hard reboot where it's going
to continue on from the original 1994
movie and
that's going to essentially eradicate
everything that happened in sg1 SGA and
SGU
and that's not something I'm necessarily
on board with as I've mentioned now it
is important to remember that with a
movie it is very different than what it
is going to be with a TV series now the
movie audience and the TV audience are
very different there are people who only
watch the original Stargate movie in
1994 and there are people who have
watched both I'm one who has watched
both I've watched a movie and then I've
watched all the series and learned all
the lore and all the Canon and watched
all the stories and I've loved the
characters that have been developed but
only a handful of those characters were
in the original movie so we had Jack
O'Neill we had Daniel Jackson we had
Catherine Langford
Scarborough was in the original movie so
was charade's Dad so it was shot Ray and
of course we had ra but something that
changed when the TV series came out was
how Ra was portrayed now in the movie ra
looked like a gray alien he looked more
like an Asgard than anything else but in
the television show they adapted it and
they created a story around it where he
was a grow old system Lord he was a
parasite living inside of a human host
that was something that was changed and
it was something that was actually a
really good change because it added so
much more depth to what could
potentially happen with Stargate we then
had a new antagonist we had Apophis
which was the brother of RA and
essentially he played the role of what
royal would originally have been in the
Stargate movie for the first couple of
seasons in sg1 we didn't know the whole
host of other gold system Lords drawing
on Earth's mythology so that is a change
that I absolutely love Roland Emerick
and Dean Devlin when they created the
original Stargate film really only
intended it to be a Trilogy of films and
the gate was only originally meant to go
to three destinations the first one of
which would have been abidos the desert
planet that looked a lot like ancient
Egypt the second one was going to be
like an Aztec planet with the Aztec
pyramids and things like that there's
going to be a story there and then the
third film was going to have a novel
location which was then going to tie in
all of Earth's of the mythologies
together so it could have been the
ancient Greeks it could have been the
Romans it could have been Norse
mythology could have been whatever it
was we don't actually know we only know
really of two which was the Egyptian
Planet abidos the first one they went to
in the movie which we actually got to
see but then there was the Aztec then
there was the Aztec planet in the in the
second movie that they never got to make
now when they created sg1 they changed
that they changed the idea and they made
it so the Stargate could actually go to
thousands millions of planets
creating a way for them to have a series
that spanned over 10 years and that is
absolutely something that I was totally
on board with the problem I'm seeing now
is if they go with a movie and they try
to do it as a continuation of the
original movie are they going to go with
the idea that the the Stargate only goes
to three destinations or are they gonna
bring in little influences from SG-1
the Stargate could actually go to
millions of planets
there are so many addresses there were
different galaxies we could travel to
are they going to include the Jafar is
it going to be a hard reboot but kind of
continue winning the tradition that's
Target sg1 brought to the table that's
something if they do go down the hard
reboot side I'm hoping they do and they
don't just come up with something
totally different because then it will
just be Stargate by name it won't be the
Stargate that we know and love and this
is something we spoke about on the
channel before if they change things
completely if they do a hard reboot and
they just do fresh ideas and things like
that it's only Stargate by name it's not
going to be the Target that we have
grown up enjoying let me give you an
example if in the movie they have an
antagonist and the antagonist is very
similar to what the girl would wear at
sg1 but not quite and they change it so
dramatically that they are very
different characters
but they also have the Stargate and the
DHD and the possibility of them being
able to travel to multiple different
planets in one movie that's still not
the Stargate that we grew up with
because because they've changed the
entire story they've changed the
characters and the only thing linking
the two will be the fact that there's a
Stargate a DHD and the fact that they
can travel to multiple planets it's not
going to be the same as what we had
before and that's something I'm really
worried about the second possibility of
course is that they do a continuation
and it follows on from the story from
sg1 SGA and SGU the only problem I can
see with that is quite a long time has
passed it's been about 13 years since
Stargate Universe left our screens and
as you know at the end of Stargate
Universe we left Eli alone on Destiny
with the rest of the crew uh in stasis
now they could do a story where they
basically tie up that storyline but for
the people who haven't seen Stargate
Universe that's going to be really
confusing because it's going to be
people that have only seen the movie and
there's going to be what I've only seen
the series I don't know although a lot
of the time those audiences connect and
they they cross over and there are
people that have seen both and there are
people have only seen the series and
there are people who've only seen the
seen the movie
it's going to be a situation where if
they do a continuation
there's going to be certain portions of
the audience who are just going to be
completely confused and that's going to
happen either way whether they do a hard
reboot or if they do a continuation so
it's really really difficult how do you
create a movie
continuing Stargate SG-1 Stargate
Atlantis and Stargate Universe
in a way that you can explain everything
that had happened before so a new
audience can come in and still follow
along but also in a way that makes it so
people who have watched sg1 SGA and SGU
can follow along as well and and see
little little Easter eggs or things like
oh yes I remember this happening and all
this is what's going to unfold because
of X that happened 10 years ago it's a
really difficult situation and I think
this is where Amazon are probably going
to be looking they're going to be
looking at okay who is the bigger
audience and I think what they're going
to find is that the television audience
is a lot bigger we're certainly the most
vocal audience we consistently make
Stargate trend on Twitter because we
want a continuation that follows on from
what Brad Wright and the rest of the
team had created all those years ago we
want something fresh we want something
new we want something that is still
Stargate and it's so difficult but who
knows what do you think let me know in
the comment section down below
how you envision a new Stargate movie to
go can you see them doing a hard reboot
could it be a continuation or could it
be a hybrid of the two let me know in
the comment section and we'll have a
chat down there
whilst you're down there hit subscribe
and press the Bell notification so you
don't miss a single video and also
consider becoming a fully flat side
tracker by hitting the join button down
below
thank you so much for watching I will
see you
next week
[Music]